hi everyone today my talk will be my
talk will be on the scaling lesson is
that took him learn over the past 45
years using the GSN production in
problem and the second part my talk will
be on IP cluster which is a small
library that we have open we have just
open source yesterday to help us with
scaling no services so I'm young bin my
friends just call you ID i'm a
co-founder also pin so we is the best
live chat company in the world it seems
150,000 websites we get 3 billion
impressions on our chat widget month and
a pic we see 500,000 concurrent
connections so in two thousand Canada
doing nov 9 and 10 we decided that we
wanted to rewrite our dashboard after
three years from flex to html5 so at a
point flag set have been really good to
us because this off all the cross
browser issues and they have TCP socket
support so we could have a chance of
survival for four orders codon streaming
data but we were getting running the
morn problems because we couldn't it was
difficult hire people at new flex and
also it was extremely difficult to
customize so designers are not happy so
we decided to do everything in html5
again and apply sauna lessons that we
learned pitting our dashboard so for
instance in the new version of our
dashboard we decided that the entire
application state would be based on
buying the body that so in the Flex
version we had usually have made an API
call in a setup fiction
to put data in and that was very tedious
and it meant that some parts of
application that when you if you know
about it to set this up you had hot
problems like when agents are entered
and so on they do not reflect on you I
so we decided that we should write a set
of not GNE servers that will help to
translate the data from our back-end
into a format next month I just over by
our front end so note was a good fit for
us at a time it was a very familiar
environment and you can think of our our
mediator service as we call them as a
kind of dynamic CDN which which means we
kind of cash or dynamic information in
our servers around the world so
distributing also was wrong we also give
us additional benefits that lower
latency is to our end users and being
able to handle the load for different
parts of the world so no Jess really
rocked it was really fast so it looks
good but the problem is of course number
communities a pressure model which is
the typical no problems which is a [ __ ]
guys single credit and we have memory
leaks in our applications they are to
track down so all problems in computer
science and software play of redirection
right so easy way out interest to buy a
couple of load balancers proxies SSL
terminators etc but because we will
start off with in have that kind of
money so we had to be a bit more
creative with how we try to schedule our
our server so these are some of the
things that we try obviously the beauty
in cluster module which works well from
hitch to be repairs but because we had
our service was live chat we had
persistent connection with our users so
that you can stream the data and this
really breaks long polling connections
because each additional each each time
the long four finishers
the browser will connect to a different
server and then you lose your whole
application state so there was out at a
time there was a web sockets for ngx
body was at a party module and was not
very live we looked at his a proxy and
start so history proxy is is a kind of
dumb proxy so the biggest problem
hitters proxy was that there was no we
could get our client IP address in our
application because we're using SSL and
he proceeded as i understand ssl alright
so we looked at stat which is the ssl
terminator so what I means is your
browser makes an ssl connection to start
start on reps that ssl encryption and
makes it normal TZ connection to your
server so you don't have to end ssl and
all the decoding or the decryption
standbys by the most start so the
application as much if you do its own
thing and you don't have to handle it
you can handle anything from you as well
so when i start for a while but and in
the next slide I will talk about how we
start the problem trying to get the
client IP address from stuff we also
look at forwarding soccer file
descriptors in Linux you can send the
file descriptor between processors so
for tcp doesn't work because you could
just send the farthest planet process
and and we can write off the 40 script
but we were using SSL so that kind of
poke the whole thing because esta has
this really opaque state that you can't
stand over socket so let me show you how
we managed to capture our client padres
so we were very happy that we were using
not because we could do things like this
which is basically heck the note HTTP
server so that what we did was start at
this option to after unwraps the
encryption for the connection since the
IP address on the client we fill in the
first four
bites of the tcp stream so what I'm
trying boo here is we are trying to
intercept that initial connection even
before the HTTP server gets it read off
the IP address and then pass it back to
the notes to note so you should be
server to do it's a healer passing it on
and others modulus ave he has to do so
as you can see what we did let me go
people we get a list of existing
connections on a tcp server and one of
these connection handlers well this
connection event handlers would be the
HTTP header process so we intersect the
connection and on one receiving any data
we attempt to oops we attempt to read
off the first few bites that mix up the
client IP address and sets it on the
socket connection and then pass through
the remaining data to the original
handler for this soccer so this works
it's a bit complicated actually because
I kind of thicken up or error handling
right and but it worked for for us for
for quite a while and so we thought
through this for maybe half a year sound
the other problems in general when you
when you talk about this kind of
multi-layer infrastructure where you
have proxies SSL two meters is that you
get buffer bill which is when all the
different components in the stack buffer
a little bit of data and so from an
application you can tell how much data
is being buffered by dresses so how much
room is still sorting our network in
whether your client has received that
they are not so after about six months
or rather for six months while we're
using stuff we occasionally got problems
we start just dies and recent god is
inexplicable errors that
that what's wrong need not because of
something I start was doing and the ssl
the tcp handler in node could not handle
this so we continue to look for a better
solution soft our scaling problem so let
me stay that we thank you give you guys
a primer on mac bus so you I guess you
have study familiar with IP addresses
and a net mass that looks like this so
II my night 1685 to 128 is the IP
address and / 26 refers to the network
at this IP address belongs to so what is
essentially means is that the first if
you click the first 26 bits of this IP
address that is the network of this IP
address so this is a way for now engines
to partition that works into site into
cyber challenge manageable chunks and
true for initiative process like you
could route data you can roll back at
space on which network you are coming
from which now we are going to so we
figured out that we could actually abuse
net masks by matching on the least
significant bits so when we measure the
most images are in a typical way that
people use that mass if we did load
balancing based on that what the problem
we will find is that you have some
networks where you have a lot of users
and sometimes very very very easy so if
you try and do load balancing that just
because you just end up with this
service they have to sell a lot of
traffic because I don't know very good
like a [ __ ] China is in one small neck
block so if you got actually we could
match on at least if you can beat and in
this way we get some sort of random
nurse when we're trying to route our
users and at the same time because it's
based on IP address so for long pulling
such different connections we still go
back to the same so so in fact the
leaner
now if you'll Ahmad you that's allow you
to match arbitrary numbers addresses
addresses so if you see there's a
bloodbath 2000 doctrine that is the
networks that we're using so what we're
saying is match the last two bits of the
IP address and that is the net block I
mean so called the slot then the client
belongs to so what we do here is for
each of these blocks we brought it we
Rida right into one of our worker
processes and this has to be a it has to
be a power of two processors because of
how the mass works so we deploy this
solution and it worked really well for
us we could scale the number of worker
processors by adjusting the number of
bits what you mentioned in this case we
are matching to bit so they are four
workers but if we had like a 30-foot
core machine and you match five bits and
half that number of other processors so
this worked very well oh no we still get
we see at some remaining issues which
which is our application our loan
application has some memory leaks and
over time it builds up n as you know
we're not kids about 1 to 2 gigabytes of
memory starts to really slow down the
process to do garbage collection on time
so what we did was once no hits around
almost manual process one key byte of
memory usage we will we will restart yes
that particular worker it wasn't so bad
in a sense that because unique
disconnects the user that users they
were connected with which is maybe one
over eight of our reasons connected to
the particular server but you are so it
was a good experience for our users so
and ok and and we also had some human
errors when we were attending the
parties rules because we generated em
manually and when we wanted to change
the number of slots the number of
workers for server it and we
updated iptables for free it would prick
so we decided to write a new likely to
help us handily handle all this iptables
manipulation and at the same time help
us manage worker processors we're
starting them when you are using flash
memory restarting and when they are when
they are running out off when they are
taking too long to respond and and so on
so these are some of the features that
our library has given in right now so
it's Monica you use it like the transfer
value in nodejs he has place to work
every time and so what it means is that
when we want Q of a worker we don't we
don't ask you it but what we do is that
we changed i became a rule respona canal
water resolve new work at first and
change hi Petey Lorusso right points in
the new worker and let over continue to
finish servicing the requested that they
are still outstanding so they're also
allows us to do hot curvy road so when
we have a new deploy we can just make a
whole bunch of new workers and point
iptables to use the use the new
processors so Batman who refers to the
fact that our new processors thus the
soccer object ADC is the actual soccer
that gets connected of client so things
like doing events they work reliably
because you don't go to another way of
proxy and obviously a client IP address
is there early on the socket three menus
of this MPI Monica too busy which posed
the note event loop and determines and
try to determine if it's taking too long
to go to the event which which implies
that the no processor is a new processes
under too much loot and is spending all
this time Henry depends so then how was
that helps us to detect work instead
have run into some kind of problem and
they are just general servicing requests
fast enough
so as I said so that sort of master
managers or the other different workers
and we use unix dominicans to
communicate between a master and the
workers the workers select the listening
pots that be a decent amount owed is
what we do is that we get the operating
system to do it so you pick a random
port and workers report the partner
listening to the master and master will
set up the IP table should make sure
that you points to the right places the
Muslims are looking above means of
managing other masters so we in just in
case there's a button while saying you
to Cuba or to run in another master I
because that is designed so that if you
run another copy of a muscle it will
queue of the 01 and manage and tip over
a single cuz i manage them properly so
we retire workers when so in a capacitor
we set a memory limit per worker and so
when workers approach the limit we will
Chris we will let them kind of shut down
gracefully by by redirecting all the new
requests to new servers basis of class
also a cluster men really mean for the
entire cluster so when you approach like
the limit of the more memories of the
entire struggle has we will find the
odors retire worker and cute so we have
open source IP castles so this is all
this our project page and now I will run
us through an example of IP cluster
usage so this is a typical route I'm
WebSocket based application we start a
web socket and on a connection we send a
current every 100 milliseconds so
slick
oops
give it over the demo happens every time
get out of the skip the demo and run
true let me just run to how we how you
want to use IP cluster and as in how how
can we use IP castor and not a Fraggle
as this thing weighs so much so if you
notice this on right side is the same
application but below we at IP cluster
support so it's assume it's as simple as
um it's actually familiar with if after
me with the cluster module in node is
actually similar you require the IP
custom module set up the seller some
settings photo so this is the socket
that the master and worker processes
communicate over it will set IP address
because otherwise we wouldn't know how
to setup you table fools so you can a
master you just set up master and sorry
let me get a worker you just start yours
your application as phenomenal except
this time you don't specify a listening
port we let we let the operating system
pick apart and then we will put the pot
to the master and that's it the master
vendor or a PTO rules so let me
what
okay so let me show you all IP tables
so I just listed all the rules in the ne
T table for for this machine and you
know this is nothing here so our now run
the select application support and we
see that we have three rules no 10 in
fall so what happened was that s each
worker was fun we reported the pot day
listening to to the to the master and
master set up the IP t was for that for
that particular slot so it always waits
until that worker report support before
creating iptables room so what this
means is that we will never create a PK
value before the worker is ready to
accept connections so let's see whether
it works this time I'm sorry I think
I've song ever so short a time but I
guess from the yeah I guess from I guess
one crow is pretty straightforward how
it works yeah so let me go back to the
future so to help us with our memory
leak issues in the future we are
planning to automate automated hippie
things about so the good thing about
article says that because we can we know
when a worker starts we can take a
snapshot of the hip and when the worker
is retired we can wait until every
single ass connection has has been
disconnected before we take another hip
and if the different so in this way we
can find memory leaks there's also it's
been hard to see the health of the
cluster
is fine time so some kind of dash
thought would be nice to be able to see
what the cluster is currently doing so
um is a shout out to my team and team
who is one of our developers and has
worked a lot on up your cluster yeah
that's all so I could we have let's say
one question maybe for young bin yes
hello I'm just wondering it you have
have you ever tried to use unless site
youíre DS RSS install so that you can
sync synchronize a session between
multiple clients so I mean you don't
really needs a sticky station ask foster
I mean for all the note and also have
you tried to use a something new
protocol which is a proxy for taco which
is allow you to load balance between
multiply and even GPU TCP so let me let
me see all your questions right the
first version so why not why not use a
very special session store yeah and we
are why you need so you can match the
income connection with the provides
instant connection yeah so this meet you
don't even eat the sticky six and as the
first place so sort of thing is we
actually a really kind of hyper session
management system which is our back-end
services so essentially for the all
mediators we could reconnect with
another mediator end we can still
répondre back to the same session but a
problem is that there is a lot of state
in our front-end service because we are
we are normalizing the data structure
into a into a global streaming standard
for our financial service so let's not
stay involved and while we can you can
reconnect or difference over it takes
a couple seconds to get all that state
or set up again so we this I mean that's
why we have we try not to have to prove
the state as much as possible